check out this week's must-see movie  nice to have you back professor  why don't they why this math of hell  Robert Langdon is back racing across  Europe to foil a deadly plot in Inferno  Dante's Inferno isn't fiction it's a  prophecy how's it going  I don't like being solid Tom Cruise is  running from the law in the action flick  Jack Reacher's never go back when I find  you a little girl is accidentally  possessed in the word killer Ouija two  origin of evil  you know what it feels like to be  strangled today here's this week's fan  tissa patient  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting below see  you next time on weekend ticket